what's going on guys this is Rob and as
much as I love covering the main fall of
X storyline I do like covering some
other stuff and so while this does take
place during fall of X and it does
reference it it's also kind of separate
at the same time but the ending to this
is crazy so for those of you guys who
didn't see the first video that we made
the only real takeaway from that is that
at some point in time Wolverine and
Ghost Rider had basically met one
another as they were both pursuing a kid
named Bram their path just happened
across they kind of fought each other a
little bit but Bram is basically this
person out there that is either
possessed by demonic power or his
inherent mutant ability or inherent
power whatever it happens to be is to
channel demonic energy I argue that he's
powered by demon bear but he's basically
returned so you have Wolverine and Ghost
Rider teaming up to track this guy down
now one of the things that they realize
in their Journeys they come across this
just kind of gigantic crime scene with
all these police lights and everything
is that not every mutant was 4 forced
off of Earth by orcas that some of them
actually went into hiding these
particular mutants were hiding in the
wood now one of the things that I want
to specify is that while Bram is
tracking down and killing different
mutants across the Earth he doesn't
really seem to be Associated directly
with orcas but the ending of this may
very well change your mind and I'm kind
of curious to see how you feel about it
but what goes on here is that in an
effort to at the very least analyze this
crime scene and see what's going on
Wolverine and Ghost Rider actually pose
as what are basically forensics guys so
once they get to like the main crime
scene itself dressing up in disguises
they literally tell the cops just go
ahead and get out of there while they
analyze the whole scene and in that
moment the Ghost Rider tries to manifest
now that's one of the things you
remember about what Benjamin Percy's
doing right now with the Ghost Rider
comics it's very much a return to the
old Ghost Rider stories from way back in
the day with just to say the Ghost Rider
Persona is almost like a demonic
barometer right the closer they get to
the demonic or evil or corrupt or
somehow negative energy the more the
Ghost Rider Persona tries to manifest
and so In This Moment it's just kind of
frustrated by the fact that it can't
come out and they can't just wipe out
anybody who's doing anything that's
particularly evil now again that's an
important distinction to understand
because in their travels they're
surrounded at all times by people who
are just doing really bad stuff maybe
it's a drug dealer maybe it's this
person doing this or that person doing
that and the Ghost Rider wants to punish
them but because the focus of Johnny
Blaze is literally just this like Tunnel
Vision on Bram It ultimately forces the
Ghost Rider Persona to kind of keep
itself at Bay but what ends up happening
here is Wolverine calls in a favor with
Jeff Bannister now Jeff banister was
introduced to us in the main Wolverine
Comics the only thing you really need to
know within the confines of this story
is that he's a contact that Wolverine
has in the CIA and so what it does is it
allows Wolverine and Ghost Rider to use
a kind of satellite office to basically
analyze everything that's going on with
regards to this mutant DNA any kind of
common trail they may have that may give
them some measure of information now
initially Wolverine's idea is to hunt
down anything or track down anything
that has to do with mutants and it makes
perfect sense just because of the fact
that Bram is killing mutants it's the
best place to start but from Johnny
Blaze's perspective this guy just reeks
of demonic energy so the best thing they
can do is to actually analyze anything
out there that has to do with demonology
right that's the best route that they
can go because while following the
mutant Trail would inevitably lead them
to Bram the idea of Johnny Blaze is
following this Trail will basically get
us there faster now the information that
they're able to glean is somewhat
helpful but it doesn't give them like a
direct beeline instead it basically
sends them on the path to the orphanage
that Bram was at when he was a younger
kid because remember remember when they
initially encountered Bram in their
younger years they didn't really know
anything about it right like Wolverine
met the little kid at some point but
because of the fight that took place
between Wolverine and Ghost Rider Bram
had basically gotten away right he was
removed from the whole situation and
there was no conceivable way to locate
him again so the best place they could
possibly do was get to this orphanage
and then just kind of go from there what
ends up happening is that once they get
in there the guy who runs the orphanage
initially thinks like they're cops or
they're like reporters or something
along those lines because they're asking
questions about the quote-unquote orphan
murders from back in the day a very well
publicized event when it originally
happened but as Johnny Blaze is walking
through there the Ghost Rider Persona
tells him to open a door that he comes
across which has all these different
locks on the outside what he does like
when he actually opens this door there's
a kid inside who's basically stuck in
one half of an iron maiden and he
basically tells them like he puts us in
here here when we're bad and In This
Moment Johnny Blaze plays the game of
yes but maybe yes it's important to keep
the Ghost Rider Persona under control
but maybe
maybe this is the time to just let it
out so he tells the kid like run you
need to leave uh you don't want to see
what's about to happen next and that's
when The Ghost Writer Persona pops out
because this guy is in effect tormenting
orphans and so Wolverine's response here
is okay something you gotta understand
man this room has now become what we
call the truth room and this is your
chance to tell the truth lest you spend
the rest of your days in agonizing pain
and suffering now what we see here is
something that we actually haven't seen
in the Ghost Rider comics recently and a
lot of you guys have asked about that a
lot of you guys have asked when are we
going to see the Ghost Rider do the pen
and stare and that's exactly what we get
it's this amazing moment right where he
says the way to extract information is
through pain and Penance and he gives
this guy the pen and snare now for those
of you guys who don't know what the pen
and stare is it's basically an ability
of the Ghost Rider her to force a person
to feel all the pain they've ever
inflicted anybody all at one time now
the pen and stairs used in different
ways sometimes it's used as a form of
punishment and literally it just kind of
leaves the person in a catatonic State
sometimes it'll kill them sometimes
they'll go insane but in this instance
it's being used for information so I
would go so far as to argue it may very
well not be the full on Penance stair
with the 100 potency that you normally
see because this guy's still conscious
he's still living right like I mean he
hasn't been driven to the point of
insanity and is like clawing his eyes
out of his head you know out of just
complete and total Madness but what he
does is he simply says somebody was here
a month ago someone asking the same
questions they took the files on brand
and so despite the fact that the files
are gone Ghost Rider is able to kind of
see the files in his own mind because of
course this guy had witnessed the files
as well those memories are transferred
they're of course in turn turn
transferred to Wolverine and that's when
he gets to see the totality of the
nature of bran that ever since this kid
was little right like when he was first
brought to the orphanage this has been
his whole stick right like going through
and I'm basically tormenting mutilating
the whole nine yards any number of
things but just appearing incredibly
Disturbed and in fact there was a
particular instance here when there was
a suspicion of him having like
schizophrenia of course we also learn
his name is Bram Stroud and so with this
information Ghost Rider in turn informs
Wolverine The Man Who removed the files
worked for the government he had a
federal warrant the address listed
should be familiar to us both hell's
Backbone in Utah where we raced the
devil once before right that took place
in the Ghost Rider comics it was a
pretty cool moment because Wolverine
basically ripped a demon out of Ghost
Rider's head it was pretty dope right
but he says it's a frail spot a place
where things spill over a perfect
location patient for their research
What's Happening Here is research is
being conducted regarding a Hellfire
addition to the weapons plus program
which is exciting for those of you guys
who don't know what this is right
anybody who's been reading Wolverine
long enough knows that like weapons plus
like when they come into the mix that's
when things get amazing because weapons
plus started out as kind of a precursor
to project wide awake right going with
Grant Morrison's X-Men run weapons plus
was an anti-mutant government agenda
that was kind of an orchestration
between the United States CIA and then
eventually Canada's Department H Captain
America was weapon one right grant
Morrison's X-Men established that and
then he got weapons two three four five
all the way up to weapon 10 which is
Wolverine also known as Weapon X the
whole idea behind weapons plus is to
basically just create super soldiers and
if they're able to find a way to harness
a being with demand like power that can
in turn be used for their own purposes I
mean it would dwarf anything and
everything that came before there's no
telling what could come out of this so
with that being said guys normally we
link to the fall of x if you guys want
to get caught up on weapons of Vengeance
as well as Ghost Rider and Wolverine
make sure you click this link to the
playlist and I will catch you all later
peace